Jennifer my love again little old me as
we know Mama Odie is wonderful and
larger than knife how could you
well how did you and dig a little deeper
to voice this voodoo of fairy godmother
well you know I went to the audition I
had auditioned for Oprah's role you know
the sweet Mama's voice I said darling
there's nothing sweet about my voice do
you have another part and I said well
can you do an old woman and I said well
my mother used to listen to all of moms
Mabley else so as a little girl I would
just sit there and listen and of course
her famous joke was the only egg
oh man can do for me
is introduced me to a young one and of
course I fell in love with her but of
course I just pulled out moms Mabley and
you know they're the lines were yojo not
emotion bonding I mean all you gotta do
is take your teeth out but I want to say
this my favorite part was in being in
the studio with Randy I wanted to please
him so much I'd sung so many of his
songs when I was doing club work in New
York and I just went in don't matter
what you're looking like don't matter
what you wear how many rings you got on
your finger we don't care no we don't oh
all right I'll just come
[Applause]